now all right welcome back this is a  really interesting  story the average american lifespan has  shortened  and dropped to its lowest level since  2003.  people are living just over 77 years and  the major culprit  cova deaths that's according to the  national center for health  uh for health statistics rather  it is unexpected to see such a decline  from  one year to the next something has to  happen for us to see something like that  the pandemic affected life expectancy  among certain ethnic groups more than  others  hispanics lost three years non-hispanic  blacks  2.9 years and non-hispanic whites  1.2 years men lost any ground they had  been gaining on women's longevity  experts don't anticipate a rebound in  life expectancy this year  interesting study